PAVNI DIWANJI: Ah, so we have
a bunch of makers and hackers
in the audience.
That's always good.
Right?
So we are really, really
enthused to have you
all again here at Google.
We are committed,
as you all know,
to the cause of encouraging
every woman to be a techmaker.
And I'm very committed
to encouraging
every woman I meet to be
a software engineer, not
because I think it
benefits Google,
but I think it
benefits the world.
Because I believe
that is what is
going to be the engine
of life for the future.
And we want to equip our side
of the house, our population,
to be tooled, no matter what
discipline they go after.
So I was here last year.
And I was really
pleasantly surprised
that it is growing and growing.
And I talked last year about
my journey and my learnings.
And it is really amazing to see
how many common elements there
are in all our stories--
my story, the stories
of the speakers today, and
also, of course, your stories.
I could tell from the questions.
I almost wanted to
answer all of them,
because having taken
off time for kids?
Yup.
Done it.
Have had a difficult on-ramp?
Yup.
Done it.
All the problems you run into.
So I'll be around if you want
to talk about that afterwards.
But today I think I was
given the responsibility
to conclude the day.
And I was thinking,
what would be
the three big things that
you can take away from today?
And I will tell
you my nominations,
and then we can of course talk
after about what you took away.
And that's always good.
So the first thing I want
to talk about is stretch.
And I think making
uncomfortable your norm.
So Avni, our keynote
speaker today,
talked a little bit about it.
She's an amazing woman.
She said, stretch
your imagination.
But I think it applies
to everything you do.
So I would say
stretch your skills.
Put yourself in new situations.
And I would say not
only in your career,
but even in your personal life.
Forcing change, I have found,
is a fabulous way to grow.
And what I always tell myself is
that awful feeling you get when
you're trying to
do something new,
I think that's a good
thing, not a bad thing.
And I've always applied
that throughout my career.
I remember when I was
with Sun Microsystems,
and we'd just
published Java, and I
was at the height of my
software engineering career.
And then I decided to
jump to do a startup.
And that same feeling
was there in my gut.
I'm like, oh, I'm not sure
I should do this or not.
I'm a bit scared what
it's going to bring.
And honestly it was the
best ride of my career,
because I grew
like I never knew.
I found talents I
never possessed.
So it's a great thing.
That uncomfortable
feeling, embrace it.
So the second thing is-- I think
Telle Whitney came and talked
to you about lifting as we go.
So I think that we focus a
lot on our diversity numbers
and how bleak the situation is.
And I mean, I look
at it, and I say,
we have to get
started somewhere.
So if you look at the
start of any revolution,
it always starts small,
and then it lights up.
And I think we are in
the light up phase.
I'm an optimist.
I like to think that way.
So Telle talked a little
bit about lifting,
and Cheryl did too in her book.
So lift as you go.
So I think I want to talk
a little bit about that.
So lend a hand, a helping hand.
Look around you.
I said make community
around you who
kind of resonate your passions.
Be part of the community,
and give back when you get.
So I think when I say
this, a lot of people say,
I don't have time.
I am pretty maxed out
between family and kids
and just keeping up with
my career and my job.
And what I say to
them is it doesn't
take-- in my experience-- it
really doesn't take very long.
Because all you have to
do is look around you
and find someone who needs a
little nudge, a little helping
hand, a little support.
In the right moment,
that's what we need.
So I will give you one example.
We just actually last month had
our global women's conference
at Google.
And there were some
amazing speakers lined up.
And about a week
before the conference,
I was thinking, well, all
this experience on the stage
is great, but what if we
use this forum to give women
Googlers who are technologists,
who are software engineers,
a voice to voice their ideas.
It was really quickly-- we
did a call for submissions
to all the women tech
at Google and said,
do you want to come and
talk about your idea?
We called it Red Talk,
because it was like TED,
but I really didn't
want to call it TED.
We wanted it to be en empowering
and inspiring experience.
So we called it Red.
And we were quite amazed.
Within a day, we got
more than 50 submissions.
And we said we want to
welcome any 10x ideas.
And we got over 50 submissions.
We had a hard time picking
the five people we wanted
to spotlight on the stage.
And every single idea that was
on the stage, that was amazing.
It was like big.
It was like game
changing, even for Google.
So what does this say?
It didn't take very much
effort to shine spotlights
on people's ideas.
It doesn't take very much effort
to help another woman in need.
It doesn't take much to help
someone who might be doing
an off-ramp because of kids.
It doesn't take very
much to help someone
with their coding problem.
I don't think it takes a lot.
It just takes a mental shift
to make it part of your day.
So lift as you go.
Remember that.
I think we need all
of you to do that.
And the third and the last one
I want to talk about is making.
Now I was backstage
here and I saw
some of the things
you guys have made.
So I think we have a lot
of makers in the audience.
I was a bit surprised that the
organizers putting all of you
to task to design and
wear watches for Google.
But it was quite inspiring
what has come out of that.
I think hikers are going to
have a wonderful experience
with this design.
So be your our own maker.
I think make your future.
Make your brand.
Make what you're about.
And make your community.
So I will tell you one-- I
have a lot of stories to tell,
but I'll tell you one
of my recent stories
that is about a year and
a half, two years ago.
I'd been working at Google
for-- this is my tenth year,
believe it or not.
So I was working
away, and I realized--
I have two daughters--
my younger daughter was
looking for trains on Google.
And instead of serving her
Thomas the Tank or something
similar, we were actually
serving her the train schedule
for Caltrain train station.
And I thought, OK,
this cannot be right.
And that is what led
the simple idea of how
wanting to help kids led
to the start of what is now
a pretty big project at Google.
It's never easy, but you
have to start somewhere.
And I think if you just
say we're going to do it,
and we can do it, then the rest
will just take care of itself.
So with that, I think I have
one nice slide to end the day.
So all the power to you.
I think you can do it.
And thank you.